thank you I I apologized for changing I
gave bill a different title the other
day but it was down in the weeds
literally it was about carbon evaluation
and accounting of biomass and i thought
i would actually step back and talk
about something else that I've been
working on and have been working on for
the last several years and this is a
report that I co-led as part of my work
on President Obama's Council of Advisors
on science and technology it's not
really agricultural research it's what i
would call meta research it's its
research on research and what it really
is a report on the entire agricultural
research enterprise of the US and in
some ways it's a nice way to start off
this discussion and thank you too bill
and everybody for for making this happen
because these are a set of really
important issues let's get right into it
we President Obama science advisors felt
that it was absolutely critical to bring
to the president's attention a set of
emerging challenges that were not being
addressed by the federal funded research
Enterprise nor by private enterprise in
the US we saw challenges with global
resources inputs of water pesticides
nutrients health issues the increasing
demand for food and of course also for
biofuels and competition and we saw also
incredible opportunities from science
and technology from the amazing
innovations in physics in engineering in
biology for new opportunities to improve
the agricultural systems and we wanted
to look at it in detail and so these are
just some of the challenges we
identified I think many of you are
probably familiar with these huge
challenges with new pests and pathogens
if you're not at a land-grant University
you probably are less familiar with
these issues but it there are there are
new strains of for example we trust that
that if they migrate here to the US
could
literally destroy our wheat harvest
there are many other concerns around the
world of emerging pests and pathogens
and it's a constant race just like with
antibiotics for human health and a raise
to keep up with the evolution of those
organisms huge challenges with water use
with the environmental footprint of
agriculture and of course how do we
continue to grow food in a changing
climate well I think we'll hear about
some of that work here today and of
course food and nutrition is is
absolutely critical we have an epidemic
in diabetes and obesity not just in the
US but all around the world and in many
ways the world epidemic is worse than
the one in the US and and then of course
the the classic role of the u.s. in
helping to create global food security
when there are shortages in various
places the timing of this report was
interesting we started this report in
the beginning of 2012 which was the
hundred and fiftieth anniversary of the
morel Act which which amazingly Abraham
Lincoln set up during the Civil War
which established the land-grant
universities that now dominate the
agricultural research effort in the US
but during that year as we were working
on this report we had one of the worst
droughts in US history fifty percent of
counties in the US were an emergency
drought conditions and the president was
getting daily briefings on the
challenges from the drought this is just
an example of what cornfield and
Illinois looked like in July and that of
course later in the year in late October
we had superstorm sandy again so the
issue of preparedness not directly
affecting agriculture per se but the
this was the backdrop of the report when
we were talking about preparing for the
agricultural system for climate change
this was very much in people's minds and
the question we asked was very simple is
the agricultural system prepared for
future challenges are new and different
types of investments needed now I know
in the big room this big I can't
possibly speak confidentially and the
reports public anyway you can look it up
p casts website in the office of science
technology policy in the White House but
let me just say a few comments sort of
off the record here if there are if
there are if there are reporters here
I'll just rely on your good taste not to
repeat them the truth is what we found
was that the US Department of
Agriculture and the overall research
system in the US for agriculture has
deep deep problems let me just give you
a few examples of what we observed here
is a graph showing different federal
agencies Department of Agriculture DoD
do et cetera and the fraction of money
coming from the intramural the dark blue
is the intramural funding you can see
that much more than any other agency the
money at USDA goes to support the
Agricultural Research Service which is
the vast majority of the intramural
money here this is very problematic even
worse and there are several other big
internal issues but the money that we
have been spending within the USDA only
about fifteen percent of it is actually
competitively awarded now to anybody
who's used to NSF or NASA or NOAA or do
a or it's just about any other federal
funding this is astounding it's almost
unbelievable and by the way this is
dramatically increased because ten years
ago it was only ten percent it's really
extraordinary and this includes the
formula funds that are given out to
universities it includes a variety of
other things but a very small fraction
of the total research Enterprise is
awarded competitively and then the other
point is that the public sector is
spending about a third of the public
plant research on just five crops and
they're felt we felt that there was a
huge overlap with what industry was
doing and that there was sort of a
question of what is the federal role
versus the private sector role the chief
scientist from one of the large grain
companies basically said to us we really
don't need them to fund corn genetics we
have two thousand corn geneticists so
let me just conclude because
six minutes and 40 seconds we we
basically ended a report on a challenge
and I think an optimistic note because
politically we really had to get the
support of the USDA for these changes
but from the perspective of Harvard let
me just say this the morel act for the
last hundred and fifty years did
something very important for this
country and led to huge innovations and
made the US the agricultural leader in
research for the world but the next
hundred and fifty years are going to
look different and we need to bring
agriculture back out of the land grants
into all of the universities to the
places where the most exciting biology
the most exciting physics is going on
and there's been a balkanization in this
country where we've seen agricultural
research at the land grants even in the
few institutions that have excellent
science departments and agricultural
sciences they tend to be isolated in
different parts of campus like in
Wisconsin so what I really love to see
today is all of this activity going on
at Harvard we are not a land-grant
institution and yet every institution
that has excellent science excellent
social science needs to be thinking
about food and agriculture for the
future thanks